most media companies trying to control
their content YouTube just seems to let
it fly well it's it's a platform that
anybody can upload content and you never
know what you're gonna get and I think
that that's from our conversation with
YouTube CEO Susan Wojcicki for CBS
Sunday morning back in 2015
huge amounts of content has been
uploaded to YouTube sits and since its
founding more than a decade ago 400
hours of new video are uploaded every
minute users watch more than a billion
hours of video on YouTube every day the
company's now setting its sights on
transforming television its new
streaming service YouTube TV lets
viewers watch live television from
networks including CBS YouTube CEO Susan
Wojcicki is with us now and we're
pleased to have her here so tell me
about what it is you're offering people
with streaming yeah so we're we're
offering a new service YouTube TV and
what we saw is that TV content is really
popular on our platform we have clips we
have highlight sports highlights but are
the next generation they just aren't
watching TV in the same way as the older
generation so if you look at the 18 to
24 demo over the last 5 years they've
seen a drop almost 40% drop in their TV
usage so we thought how can we take all
the great content that's on TV and how
do we make it available for the YouTube
generation so how do we make it on
demand mobile searchable great
recommendations we have a cloud DVR what
competitive advantage do you have well
it's searchable Google is great at
search YouTube's great at search
personalized recommendations unlimited
cloud DVR so you don't have to mess in
any way you just hit the star and then
that show is saved forever for you on
the well it's a skinny bundle it's only
$35 a month I mean that's one of the
main for many young people who don't
want to pay the $200 a month cable bill
or more you can get a skinny bundle on
YouTube yeah so price is a huge factor
so the $35 a month first
six accounts that makes a really big
difference for our users and it's a way
to bring the next generation and young
people back to TV like we think TV has
great content how can we bring it back
but use all the latest technology and
delivery and to make that available you
say no mobile most of its seen on mobile
yeah mobile is a big factor so YouTube
right now we see all the growth that we
see is in mobile people want to be able
to watch the their TV their kind of
wherever they are you know in their
bedroom on they want to take it with
them they want to take it you know I
feel like such a dinosaur at the table
I've got nine cable boxes yeah you know
in every different room and so I marvel
at how YouTube has really changed the
game it used to be just watch all videos
and now people go there and get all
sorts of things you saw this coming
didn't you Susan yeah well we saw mobile
is like a huge change a huge new
opportunity and you know for a long time
we used to talk about being in the
living room but like that's a screen
that is wired to the wall um like your
your TV doesn't need to be wired to the
wall you can just take it with you and
so everyone's carrying a TV around with
them in their pocket but you say this
about YouTube it's more than just a
video site it has a greater
responsibility to the world what do you
mean by that
yeah so we are a platform now that has a
billion people coming to us a month and
we just announced that we are have a
billion hours watched every single day
on our platform and so we realized we
have really broad reach and we want to
make sure that we're as a platform are
using it for good and so we're
constantly thinking about that but one
thing that we just did recently was we
announced this program called creators
for change where we identify out
creators on our platform who are doing
really good work to anti-bullying to
fight xenophobia to talk about LGBTQ
issues gender issues and to that promote
tolerance like how can you help people
see the other side how can you help
understand people different than
yourself
and they do some that sometimes with
humor sometimes their beauty bloggers
the other you're promoting them that
other side is key we should talk about
to the culture questions that are going
on in Silicon Valley specifically ones
that have been focused on uber and
Travis kalanick you wrote an
Vanity Fair about this what do you see
is the central question well I think the
central question is how do we have more
women in Silicon Valley so right now if
you look at Las Silicon Valley companies
it there about 30 percent and that's
just not enough so technology is one of
the greatest forces of change that we
have right now going on our society it's
change in all areas and so if you only
only have 30 percent of those change
makers being women that's a problem and
when yes now go ahead a MIDI is part of
the issue tracting women - computer
science that's definitely a really big
issue we need to attract more women to
computer science right now the number of
women getting computer science degrees
is about 20% and that's not sufficient
right and there's no reason women are
good at computer science women can be
great at it and I don't have a computer
science degree you don't have right oh I
actually come in computer science degree
yeah so I have a history in literature
degree I took I took an economics and
the MBA I took my first computer science
class my senior year in college because
I realized a little late and it's funny
because I the time thought wow it's too
late for me to learn and I realize it's
really never too late to learn you can
always learn and you don't need to learn
everything you just need to be willing
and wanting to learn and not all tech
jobs require a computer science degree
you can work at Google you or get
YouTube there's so many things marketing
sales support legal HR you don't have to
have a tech degree well I hope the times
are changing there you know Nina Shaw is
a badass legal attorney talent earning
in LA and she says is if you want to be
a woman in power then empower other
women and you were certainly one of
those people sitting there at the table
thank you well I'm working really hard I
want to guide young women to come I
think it's a great career it's creative
it's fun it's social and we need more
women and if you want to think about how
to change the world how to be a leader
in the next generation for the next
generation like knowing and
understanding technology is a really
important factor in the state of Silicon
Valley actions speak louder than words
we'll see thank you thank you very much